the biggest advantage that you could
bring to your business to outrank and
outsell your competition is to bring
more of yourself and your own interests
and tie it into the business because
nobody else can do that otherwise if
you're an average company selling an
average product at average prices you're
gonna get average results at best hi I'm
Evan Carmichael your friend in all
things entrepreneurship and today Mason
a question from one of our readers
George who wanted to stand out he wants
a strategy to stand out against rival
firms and competitions so thanks the
question George it's a big problem a lot
of entrepreneurs face you know we're up
against often big competitors who are
selling maybe better products or better
service definitely have much bigger
marketing and promotional budgets and
what we have and it can be tough looking
at them in the face every day the best
way that I can think of the standout and
I've seen work over and over and over
again is make your business personal
people like to buy from people they
don't like to buy from big companies and
the more you can tell your story and
incorporate your own personal interests
into the business the more you're gonna
attract other people who are like you
and who like you they're gonna buy more
from you they're gonna refer more people
to you and you're gonna have a lot more
fun running your business and make a lot
more money doing it - an example a buddy
of mine named rich is a fashion
photographer and he came to me and he
photographed celebrities and fashion
models and he says he has this interest
in writing about lifestyle and he's got
a little bit of an unorthodox lifestyle
that's that's cool and funky and he
unschooled his kids and and isn't a lot
of unorthodox things which is awesome
and he thought that might damage his
brand if he wrote about that on his web
sites we wanted to have a new site that
just talked about this kind of stuff as
if rich you gotta you gotta pack it in
you got to make it part of the whole
package because the more you talk about
yourself and showcase your story what
you're interested in one the more people
are going to be drawn to that and be
curious and want to learn more about you
and and want to hire you and to the
people who like your stories and can
relate to it if they're deciding between
you and somebody else and ten other
faster photographers what's gonna make
the difference it's a personal
connection that they feel with each
person and by having your story in your
in your website and all your marketing
material you're able to create a
personal connection and attachment to
people even though you've never met them
in your life so one example of a strange
thing that rich will do is he'll use
lemon lemon juice as his deodorant so
he's looking for an all-natural
deodorant and so he uses lemon juice as
as his deodorant and that's off the wall
and it's strange and it's funky but it
works for him and I said rich let me ask
you are your clients a little bit off
the wall and funky and strange and he
said the ones that I like to work with
are which was an interesting answer
because the ones that he likes to work
with arguably the ones that he delivers
the best results for and has the most
fun with and want to come back and work
with him again because if he likes work
with them they'll probably like working
with him and they're gonna love that
kind of stuff if they read that on his
blog and he said Wow rich is one cool
guy compared to all these other fashion
photographers who are just putting up
their catalogue online that's gonna seal
the deal he's gonna attract more people
to his business that are ideal fits and
clients for him they're gonna have more
things to talk about they're gonna have
a better connection they're gonna spend
more dollars with him they're gonna come
back more often and they're gonna refer
their friends
don't hide behind a corporate looking
website you're losing out and wondering
your biggest advantages as an
entrepreneur we all have our passions
outside of our regular business --is
right for me I love salsa dancing I love
being a salsa deejay I love the Toronto
Blue Jays I love riding my Vespa I talk
about that stuff in my videos I talk
about that stuff on my website
people who like baseball end up writing
to me we end up doing business together
people who always wanted to learn salsa
write to me we're not doing business
together
having those personal points and making
that part of your business is an awesome
way to stand out from everybody else and
attract the right clients to your
business I still want you to have a
great product or service I still want
you to have a great value offering that
you're giving out there to the
marketplace but this is the way to stand
out this is the way to differentiate
yourself and I hope you'll apply it to
your business I know it can be hard
putting yourself out there a little bit
sharing more personal details start
small start with a picture of yourself
with a big smile just having that alone
as a start and telling your story as to
why you started this business why you're
so passionate about it will draw people
in and make them curious make them want
to work with you make you want to learn
more about you
I hope you'll do it I hope you do it
today
and start taking action it's a good luck
George for those of you guys watching if
you like the video please give it a
thumbs up I may just want to do more
videos for you and I'd love to hear what
you have to think if you want to leave a
comment under the video I always read
those and appreciate them when they come
in so thank you and I will see you on
the next episode